- Weirded out by the --
(audience laughs)
You excited?
That makes so much sense.
(electronic music)
Morning everyone.
As I'm like just trying to spend more time
and create context,
I've been running in parallel one-on-ones
and these smaller groups.
This is the biggest group
I've done this with.
Mainly I just want to kind of
take more opportunities in
2018 to like download you guys
on things on my mind,
things that I'm seeing
and create opportunities for you guys to
just ask me questions and
things of that nature.
That's the spirit of this morning.
I just walked through the renovations.
So crazy.
I'm so excited.
It's gonna look so amazing.
So obviously a couple weeks from now,
I'm sure the vibes are gonna
be pretty extraordinary.
2018's off to a really
interesting and exciting start.
For me, my dream when
I started this company
was create the greatest
communications machine.
Hence why we have every capability,
media-buying, creative studio, publishing,
and be very comfortable in
doing for good, for profit,
altruistic, world domination,
honey empire, right?
We haven't even started
with how intense this is all gonna be.
We're gonna be at the forefront of it,
as a communications machine.
We started as a community management shop.
(audience laughs)
You excited?
That makes so much sense.
(audience laughs)
This company did one
thing eight years ago.
It paid us and we replied
to people on Twitter.
There's a lot of things
that I want to be better at this company.
I can probably spend the rest of my day
putting them on a list, but
at a macro we're so right.
And so to offset it, I
want to be able to be
your muse on you micro, right?
I want to fix your micro, 'cause
on a macro we're gonna win.
I'm so thankful
'cause so many of you have
been here for a while.
I just want you to win
in that environment.
My success is that I prefer change.
I'm comfortable in change
and I realize that
change is the only thing
that allows you to win in the long term.
The 98% of the human race and
maybe higher doesn't like it.
We're having a macro change.
We're having a societal change.
You know, like, I'll be honest with you.
I'm like ambitious and realistic.
One of the biggest reasons I
kinda went even harder core
at my personal brand 15 months ago,
back to what's worked for us,
which is like, "Hey, here's my example."
At least it's something to hold.
I was like, "Fuck it.
I'm gonna make myself the
most famous person in America
on this theory, and then
it will be undeniable."
And, by the way, it's working.
I'm really good at under-priced
attention and culture.
I really am.
You know it's so funny, you
start realizing your life.
It's why I was good at baseball cards.
I decided Frank Thomas and Kenny
Lofton were gonna be better
than most people thought,
so I just bought a lot of rookie cards
for under-priced costs and I was right.
But what I'm really great at
is I understand consumer
behavior and attention
just fast enough and
earlier than most people.
I've got an uncanny ability of that.
Let me build a machine around that.
So for the last nine years,
I've built a company called VaynerMedia.
We're a $200 million company
in revenue with no funding
that does agency work
and we own a female publishing
company like Refinery 29.
My ambition is to build out
the communication Death Star
to deploy it against my personal brand,
the non-profits I care about,
but ultimately my goal is
to buy the New York Jets,
and the way I think I'm gonna do that
is I'm gonna buy iconic brands
and things that mattered in the world
that are gonna get fucked
over the next decade
and then I'm gonna
re-brand them and run them
through my machine.
I'm building this huge
agency media company
that is really just a front and a proxy
for my long-term ambitions.
It trades under-priced
attention and culture
more efficiently than I think
any other machine out there
right now and that's why cool
things are happening for me.
- [Speaker On Phone] I love
how you wanna buy the Jets.
They could use your help.
- Preach it brother.
I've been a long suffering fan since '82
and somewhere along the line I realized
the only way I'm gonna
get fuckin' Super Bowl
is if I do it myself.
(inspiration music)